a creation of path now what we're
thinking about is what is the what is
the the plot traced out by a projectile
how can we describe it another way to
phrase that question in language you're
perfectly familiar with is what's the
locus of all the points that a
projectile passes through okay that's
what we're trying to think about now
what would your first guess be actually
let's do this on the count of three okay
okay three I want you to say what what
shape do you think that matches that one
two three
who said okay now a parabola is a good
guess it's a very good guess okay but a
guess isn't enough it's sure enough it
does look like a present but just
looking at something is not enough of a
justification not prove it for you if
you take a cable or any kind like a a
bridge or a string or anything like that
and you suspend it from its two ends
right and you just let it hang by it's
going away that looks to me like it's
also kind of the bottom of a parabola
doesn't it it's pretty similar yeah and
you might guess that if I kept on going
it would um you know they'd go up like a
problem like a thing but the thing it
doesn't if at this shape is not a
parabola it's what we call a catenary
I don't know if I'm pronouncing that
right but it has nothing to do with
parabolas I mean it looks very
superficially the same but it's it's not
described by a quadratic function at all
actually it's described by what we call
the hyperbolic cosine function if you've
got your calculator there at least on my
calculator in the middle where you've
got your three trig functions right you
have a look if I'm whether I've got here
we go
sorry so they the middle right cosine
cost and then this is weird but in the
middle which you never ever used and
says hi right that type stands for
hyperbolic you press that and then
there's like trig functions come up on
your screen but they like they're not
the trig functions you know they're
hyperbolic sine hyperbolic cos
hyperbolic tanh they pronounced
shine cost don't ask me like I didn't
make it up I'm just telling you okay now
what are they
they're actually hyperbolic cosine is
this function now you'd know enough to
work out what that looks like and when
you graph it when you graph it it looks
like this that's what it looks like
there's nothing like a parabola actually
when you go down to brass tacks
so therefore this shape the projectile
shape looking like a parabola is nice as
a conjecture but how do we actually
prove it okay so here's what I'm gonna
suggest we have a we have x and y
coordinates right I want to work out Y
as a function of X okay Y is function of
X the problem with that though is that I
don't have Y as a function of X I have
it as a function of T right and I have X
as a different function of T okay no
soda string any bellows we actually know
exactly what to do with this if you
think back to end of year 11 okay let me
try and um jog your memory underneath
this you can make a subheading which is
eliminating parameters what's a
parameter
this parameter is this idea of a third
and other variable that you can
introduce into your equations right
which relates the two equations to each
other right the particular kind of
parametric's we thought that was
conveniently enough parachute to the
parabola right so do you remember what
are the parametric coordinates of a
point any point only do travelers in a
row to a P P for perimeter right and
what was the AP squared good so I wanted
to go back to how do you eliminate a
parameter when you've got these two
independent sorry they're not they sort
of in the pedal but they're not really
these two connected equations that are
connected by this rule okay what do we
do do you remember if what I want is Y
is a function of X okay so what I'm
going to do is well I'll try and get P
out of one of the equations okay and
doesn't matter which one you pick but
probably the easiest one is to go in
this one
I want P on its own all I have to do is
divide by 2a so it gives you P equals
this okay and you can sub that into this
equation is this reading bills so Y is
equal to a X onto a squared so
successfully eliminated the parameter
that's what I was trying to do right and
now if I just multiply this out this is
ax squared on 4a squared so Hayes cancel
cancel and that's what leaves you video
familiar expert equals four and one
luckily okay so sweet
that's how we do it if we know what our
function of X is and a function of Y is
in terms of parameter we can eliminate
it okay so here's what we gonna do we're
interested in running this specific
parabola we want to work out the
projectiles right so I'm gonna need to
have X&Y as functions of T and then I'll
go ahead and eliminate T as a parameter
so let's start off like this let's
assume projection from the origin okay
which is the way we usually start off
predict our questions just because it
makes but numbers easier right in other
words when t equals 0 x equals 0 and y
equals 0
okay so where does every single
projectile motion question begin what we
were at first I got I got two equally
balanced diamonds
it's going to be an acceleration to quit
equation right why would the other let's
just start with the X because that's
alphabetical okay so horizontal
acceleration in a projectile motion
question is equal to zero so we're going
to integrate up I need to get all the
way up to X as a function of time okay
so my first integration name to be on a
constant okay and this cost that when we
get that from you can enjoy your
rectangle right and it's going to have
some it's gonna have some vertical sorry
not vertical some angle velocity and
you're gonna have your alpha there okay
for your initial angle okay so therefore
you're gonna get your evaluate your
constant and you're gonna get V cos
alpha right so that's fine integrate one
more time and you're gonna get the t cos
alpha plus your new constant
and because we've defined that we
started at the origin you slap in T
equals zero x equals zero so your second
constant also zero
so this is kind of our generic
displacement equation for a regular
projectile question okay all right let's
rinse and repeat for y so we start with
vertical acceleration being negative
gravity right good so integrate what's
in this constant again comes from this
kind of rectangular scenario here right
so instead of V cos alpha I'm gonna have
gonna have right okay so there's my Y
dot integrate one more time and I'm
gonna get minus GT squared on to write
plus v2 sine alpha plus my final
constant which is also going to turn out
to be zero because I started at the
origin okay so once more with feeling
here's my generic X equation he's my
generic Y equation four minus GT squared
over two it's the angular component all
right now remember what we did before to
eliminate a parameter we got one of the
parameters or the apprentice out of one
of the equations okay which do you think
we should go for probably that one right
because there's only one parameter there
whereas there's two here it's a bit of a
mess so I just want T on its own I'm
gonna say therefore divided by well
because alpha by the looks of it right
so I've got X over that
so now bring that over to your Y
equation instead of T squared yeah I'm
gonna have this minus G onto I'll put
that out the front just so it's a little
clearer I wanna explain everything you
know this is going to be X on V cos
alpha or squared
yep plus V now here's another T right so
another X on the V cos alpha
so we can tell you this up a little bit
right sorry
what do you got here think about this
okay this is minus G on - and I've got V
cos alpha down here now G the Alpha all
constants okay all constants so this is
good what I'm getting is at x squared
out here which is sort of what we are
hoping for right so if I put this like
so minus G on to V squared cos K Alpha X
square I'm just trying to make that
coefficient obvious on its own okay
and what do you got over here from my
B's cancel right so that's nice I've got
sine alpha on cos alpha so that's gonna
become 10 so what I end up here is with
X actually put there 10 out front to
make it a coefficient so you can see
maybe you want to put this in there's
another color but what we've got is what
we expected it's a minus ax squared plus
BX negative because it's projected and
it's being pulled down by gravity